Now I'd like to talk a little bit about how random testing
fits into the larger software development process.
So first of all, I just want to start by asking a question, why is it that random testing works at all?
And I don't think the answer to this question is actually known in any kind of a detailed sense.
But we do know parts of the answer.
The big part is that random testing is based on very weak hypotheses, about where bugs live.
And what I mean by this is every test case that we run is a little experiment.
The input to the experiment is a test case and the outcome of the experiment is a bit of information
about whether the system worked or it didn't work.
What random testing does is it makes the conditions,
under which we are running the experiment weaker.
We don't have to guess about some particular thing that might fail.
What we're rather doing is guessing about a whole class of things that might possibly fail.
This turns out to be powerful because, given the very complex behavior of modern software,
people don't seem to be very good about forming good hypotheses about where bugs lie.
Second reason is people tend to make the same mistakes
while they're coding and while they're testing.
For example, if Iforget to take into account some sort of a special case
while I'm implementing my system then I'd probably also forget to test it.
What I mean by this is that if I forgot to implement some feature or if I miss-implemented on feature,
I'm not going to test the stuff that I did wrong because if I was able to think of the test case,
I probably would have got the feature right in the first place.
Random testing to some extent get us out of this problem because it can construct test cases
to test things that we don't actually understand or know very well.
The third reason is there's a gigantic asymmetry between
how fast computers are and how fast people are.
Evidenceen if the random tester is mostly generating stupid test cases,
if it can generate a clever test case, maybe one in a million times just by getting lucky,
then that still might be a more effective use of our testing resources than writing test cases by hand.
And there has been a similar finding in other areas.
For example, the game Go has an extremely large state space and it was traditionally thought
that computer Go players were just never going to be very good.
The game was just too hard.
What turned out to be the case is, is that today's computer go players
are quite a bit stronger than previous ones, and they're based on
what are called Monte Carlo methods, which are simply randomized methods for exploring
small parts of the Go state space and it turns out that this is often good enough
to create respectively strong players.
They're still not nearly as good as the best human players, but they do pretty well.
And I feel this is exploiting sort of a very similar insight to random testing
where we probabilistically explore these spaces that are very large
and even if we can't achieve any kind of meaningful coverage,
we can still often find interesting things, especially if we have this
extremely fast 4- and 8-core machines that are really quite cheap today.
Now, I'd like to ask a slightly different question, which is
why random testing is so incredibly effective on commercial software, at least sometimes?
What I don't want to do here is start some sort of a debate
about whether random testing is or isn't effective.
I think there's pretty ample evidence, so for example the fuzzer papers
that we discussed yesterday or the talk that you can watch online, babysitting an army of monkeys.
People shown that random testing really is effective on commercial software. Why is that?
I'm going to give some opinions, and of course, you should feel free to disagree with these.